en la inmensidad del himalaya en la
frontera entre china y pakistán se
encuentra el segundo pico más alto del
mundo el k2
una montaña de más de 8000 metros de
altura en enero este grupo de
escaladores nepaleses logró lo imposible
al llegar a su cima a una altitud de
8.611 metros durante el invierno uno de
ellos lo hizo sin siquiera ayudarse con
oxígeno para dos de los escaladores que
se unieron a la expedición el simple
hecho de pensar sobre el ascenso aún les
produce escalofríos lo más difícil fue
el clima nadie antes que nosotros había
escalado el k2 durante el invierno el
clima allá arriba en esta época del año
puede cambiar en cualquier momento en
sólo segundos la temperatura cerca de la
cumbre cae por debajo de menos 60 grados
es muy difícil de simular en estas
condiciones para inmortalizar sus
hazañas estos deportistas extremos
filmaron a lo largo de su ascenso
creo que esta es una de las escaladas
más difíciles que hemos hecho y es muy
difícil encontrar un camino a través de
las grietas con poco aliento tuvieron
que cruzar algunos pasajes
particularmente técnicos como esta pared
de roca y elod de 400 metros de largo a
una altitud de más de 7000 metros cuando
dejaban de moverse el frío los
paralizaba y el interior de sus tiendas
de campaña los vientos eran abrazadores
a medida que las temperaturas caían a
menos 36 grados
después de varias semanas de escalada
uno a uno iban llegando a la cima hasta
que por fin lo lograron todos juntos
cantando el himno nacional de nepal